hello everyone today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key using this Pro key box
kit to begin you must have one working
key to add any additional key this kit
is compatible with 2018 to 2013 Jeep
Grand Cherokee if you want to know
whether your car makes this list I will
cover what cars do and don't at the end
of this video this kit comes with the
aftermarket key the programmer tool and
the instruction manual if you have your
own unprogrammed key you can also
purchase the programmer tool separately
as an alternative option to save
money this tool will work on any
aftermarket key or the original
key today we'll program the aftermarket
key with the kit first then we will use
the kit to program our own unprogrammed
original Dodge key
once you use this programmer tool it
will lock to your car Vin this means you
can reuse it as many times as you want
in your vehicle but you cannot use it in
any other vehicle for safety reasons so
to begin the process you need to connect
the tool to the OBD
board once you connect you can insert
the original key that is already
programmed into the ignition and turn it
to the on position do not start the car
from there the tool will show the models
to select from select the model of your
car in my case it is Ram then on the
next screen choose 1500 next press enter
and choose the year of your car make so
we're working on the 2011 Ram
1500 it will give you a range so I
choose from 2009 to 2012
enter next the screen will say press the
brake and start the vehicle so press the
brake and start your vehicle to get to
the next
step now it will be connecting to your
vehicle once it says turn the ignition
off and remove the key turn the ignition
off and remove the key
now the tool will tell you to insert
your new key here is my new
key so insert it into the ignition and
turn it to the on position but do not
start the
car within a few seconds here you will
hear the tool beep and now it's all done
your key is ready to go you can test
your key by starting the vehicle as you
can see here it's working now in our
case we will also program the second key
to do this we will repeat the
steps start by shutting the car
off and then unplug the pro key box
[Music]
tool here we will repeat the same step
except we will use the new key we just
programmed to program the second key so
again insert the key and turn it to the
on position then choose your model of
car and the year for me it is Ram 1500
the year 2009 to
2012 now press enter and it will tell
you again to press the brake and start
the
vehicle next press
enter and let it connect until it tells
you to to turn the ignition off then
once it does remove the key and turn the
vehicle off here is our next
unprogrammed original Dodge
key repeating the same steps as before
insert the key into the ignition and
turn it to the on position do not start
the
car you'll have to wait a few seconds
before you hear this
tone this means it is all done so next
Let's test the key
here we can see it's working and it's
all good to go hope you enjoyed the
video thank you for watching